hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in to another episode of left to
be talked today is Monday July 17th and
this episode is brought to you by my
fantastic motorcycle sponsor you know
and love them it's been over a year
they've been sponsoring this podcast
these guys rock it's El Cajon Harley
hell yes it is El Cajon Harley you know
you need two wheels you need a
harley-davidson it's summertime what are
you doing you've been waiting all your
life to get a bike go do it you can get
financed go on the website El Cajon
Harley calm and fill out the
pre-approval right on the website or
spin into the shop and test ride
something man go in there ride yourself
a Dyna or maybe a road king or a break
out or a Sportster anything get your ass
on two wheels come on don't be foolish
its motorcycle season all year around in
Los Angeles so there's no excuse that
you don't have two wheels splitting
lanes getting to where you need to
[ __ ] get forget about that traffic
get on a motorcycle a harley-davidson
from El Cajon and Harley located in
Southern California I don't care where
you live fly into San Diego my boy Greg
Riley will pick you up and you can ride
home you'll never forget it
Sturgis is coming up get your ass to
Sturgis I'll tell you what I've been
many times and it is epic you want to do
something in your life that you'll never
forget ride to Sturgis maybe get your
bike serviced a lot of people don't
sleep on get your bike serviced don't be
like [ __ ] around that's only two
wheels get some new tires or you know
get your brakes check oil change
anything you need also Elko and Harley
has all kinds of cool [ __ ] like bikes
bands of bikinis first Saturday of every
month they also got the Padres ride to
Petco Park July 16th which just happens
so that doesn't matter and oh they're
giving away some Metallica tickets go on
their website and find out about that
given away Metallica tickets that's
going to be
okay all right guys El Cajon harlot
follow me on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook
[Music]
let's get into a little bit of the
episode here just walked in the door
from Grand Rapids Michigan and Detroit
and it's funny to think you know it
never gets old to me man going to
different spots and seeing seeing you
know people that love the podcast it's
just amazing I was out there in Grand
Rapids
did this crazy venue opening for Bill
burr which thank you so much bill cannot
thank that guy enough he has just been a
[ __ ] just a lifesaver in my comedy
career I love that guy and he is a
complete inspiration to get to watch him
do hours of comedy I just learned so
much so not only do I get the open form
but it's like being in comic you know
comedy college just sitting there
watching a [ __ ] master up there slay
these people on a boiling hot
incinerating room it was blazing in this
place it was an old church I think it
was built in 19 or sorry 18 1864 68
right around then and it looked exactly
like if you saw King Diamond on the last
couple tours it looked exactly King
Diamond set you can look at it in my
Instagram Dean Del Rey and see what this
place looked like it was fantastic I
just came out there like you know just
merciful fate in it and so it's
something so crazy about doing just dick
jokes in a church I just up there like
yeah man it was awesome and the people
all the people that came to the shows
Wow just phenomenal for no [ __ ] in
the crowd that's right
I learned something over and over be a
you know going out and working with like
Joey Diaz or Marin or burr
when you have your own audience it's
just phenomenal because you know when
you're just doing a club you know like
say The Comedy Store and you're popping
in or whatever there's different peoples
from all around the world and they you
know they might not know who you are but
they know the next comic or you know
whatever but when you have your own
audience man which I learned on Sunday
night in Detroit I was doing a rock club
shout out the cat and everyone at smalls
in Detroit this place was amazing they
hit me up this is some gorilla gorilla
booking and some some next-level I love
this kind of thing she follows me on
Instagram she books this Club smalls
rock Club famous rock club and she was
like hey I see you're going to be in
Grand Rapids do you want to spin up to
Detroit on the Sunday and headline here
to rock Club and I was like yeah [ __ ] it
let's do that man and I'm so glad I did
it it was a room full of a room full of
just people that listen to let to be
talk and of course that have heard me on
like Rogan or Marin or or Joey Diaz
Church of what's happening it was a room
full of those people and my point is
although there's you know a small group
and you know of course birds are huge
you you realize how great it is to be
performing in front of people that know
everything about you I could go on these
you know journeys I could take the
audience into some storytelling I could
riff I could talk about things from the
podcast and they know what I'm talking
about it was just absolutely it was one
of my favorite headlining shows I've
ever done and everybody that was at the
gig holy [ __ ] were they cool heavy music
fans heavy comedy fans those two
together man make for I realize an
amazing audience so thank you Bill thank
you
Grand Rapids thank you doctor grins and
Stewart
up for letting us drop in on your show
um on Friday and Saturday after the sets
at the fountain Street Church bill and I
on Saturday went over and popped in a
dr. grin to comedy club which is just so
cool
it's great for me because you're doing a
giant giant venue and then BOOM get
yourself grounded get yourself right
back into the [ __ ] club and don't get
delusional keep working and you know
that's what it's about
anyway fantastic weekend and thank you
everybody that came out I love all you
guys
my guest today it could be one of the
all-time all-time dream guests for me
you know I remember 1981 or 82 I've told
this story many times I was in the
record factory in Santa Rosa California
it was the one underneath the 101
freeway I walked in there's a woman
working there name's Kat she managed a
lot of local bands and I said what's
happening she's like you got to check
this band out and she handed a piece of
vinyl to me and on the cover it just had
a [ __ ] guy in leather pants just a
crotch shot with [ __ ] spiked belts
and handcuffs and a and a fingerless
glove and you know I'm looking at it
like this looks cool I turn it over I go
whoa look at these [ __ ] guys I
remember I went home I popped it on came
on it was like cloud me and I'm a lab
Dannette out on the streets again I was
like [ __ ] I'm in I'm in from that day on
Motley Crue was deep and my [ __ ]
blood went Psalm at the Santa Rosa vets
scanners opened that was Jim Kucera my
memory is working good today
Jim casera
from vicious rumors had started his own
band we are friends he goes come down i
sat on the stage I took some insane
photos a motley 5 feet away there they
were just I mean these guys were [ __ ]
rock gods man it was crazy you know you
got to think ed van Halen and and then
you know four years your rocket van
Halen you rock a Judas Priest scorpions
and all that and all sudden here comes
the [ __ ] New Kids on the Block and
they're taking [ __ ] names you know
and then a masterpiece called shout at
the devil comes out where I see him at
the Warfield and I meet some long
lifetime friends Burnie rod and Billy
Rowe from jet boy and we had dreams to
start our own bands from then on mana
some Motley pretty much every tour Psalm
with the with the girl drummer Psalm at
that what the Warfield when Tommy Lee
just got out of jail Fillmore I saw him
at I've seen him huge Oakland Coliseum
Cow Palace Psalm at the you know Dan the
green one of the all-time biggest you
know eighties rock festivals ever put
together it was motley Whitesnake jet
boy and someone else I [ __ ] spacing
it right now but anyway
you saw the band many many times I've
always loved them I even saw him on the
farewell when they signed the contract
jimmy kimmel I was there standing on the
stage Thank You Don Barris for setting
that up yeah Motley Crue [ __ ] great
I'm one of those guys if anybody said
different I'd be like Garrity or [ __ ]
mind
listen these songs are so great that
shout at the devil too young to fall in
love Hollywood of course the title track
all the records had something they
changed their look over and over I was
constantly like holy [ __ ] now they're
like girls
oh now they're bikers now they're
[ __ ] Queen what's good you know and
then they drop dr. feelgood and that
thing is just a Smasher I could talk on
and on and on about them let's just get
into this but I just wanted to give you
a little rundown of what how monumental
the guest is to me and to be friends
with Nikki Sixx is just insane we're
going to do this interview a while ago
and the morning that we were scheduled
to do it Chris Cornell had passed and
neither of us were in the mood to talk
so I was just thank God that it got
rescheduled because I know Nikki's
completely busy man check out a show
sick sense if you've never heard it
you must be sleeping under a rock I was
on it last month six cents you could go
to Nikki's page and just listen to that
right there on the page I want to thank
him one more time and I want to tell you
guys before I do kick off the interview
yes
I could have asked him a thousand
questions and yes I could interviewed
him for four or five hours but I'm not
the guy that writes down questions I
just let a natural conversation go and
that keeps it organic and cool believe
me I had 100 more questions I wanted to
know did Tommy Lee's crazy drum kits
come out of the [ __ ] Bands pot you
know what I mean did they try out other
singers other than kuraby when they were
looking at singers besides Vince who
came in what was it like playing with
Blackie Lawless yeah I got a million
questions and hopefully I'll do a part
two but if not thank you for just
sitting down with me once Nikki before I
get into it some upcoming shows here
Toronto you're next on the Road Rash
tour I'm coming your way
let's see July 26 through the 30th
they'll be at the corner with red band
and Sam Tripoli August 10 11 12 I
returned to the hometown San Francisco
with Joe
we'll be at the punch line cannot wait
for that September 6 prey improv on
headline of one night only get your ass
out there and what else do I got oh
there's a gig in November 2nd I will be
with bill burr in sir I awoke played
last I [ __ ] should know the name of
that but I don't right now this episode
is brought to you by my Rolex sponsor
that's right Rolex sponsor in the
podcast st. crass Rolex
they are the official Rolex dealer don't
go to any of those gray markets get your
watch at an official Rolex dealer saint
cross in Koreatown how cool is this man
I love watches they have all kinds of
watches other than Rolex also they have
Pantera and a bunch of other brands but
Rolex are the specialty and they have
every model in their Daytona's
submariners sea dwellers sky dwellers
gate just to 88 40s all my favorite
watches I love them all go see sink
cross ask for Andy they are on Western
Avenue go down there Koreatown an
official Rolex dealer get that five year
warranty don't go gray market don't buy
your [ __ ] on eBay and not be able to
sleep at night get your watch at saint
cross let's get into it right now it is
time for the man Nikki Sixx you look
good oh thank you did look healthy I've
been [ __ ] you know I quit sugar for
like it's been 14 months now that that's
that's my drug yeah me too heroin yeah
it's spirity you know why because we've
been doing it since we were one year old
you know tomato yeah you do drugs
whenever you start drugs but it when you
start those drugs it's like way later in
your life maybe 16 18 or whatever but
but cereal milk everything either in it
crisp cereal you're not old enough to
know about that yeah crisp cereal
I would just die if I'm in my quiz sir
it was like a little saucer like a
little and there was like that on the
box was like a little alien yeah his
name was quispe yeah and he rode around
in this sugar you know sugar ball sugar
spaceship and I just let them all fly
into my mouth and now a sugar addict
right there was one when I was growing
up called King vitamin zero vitamins in
and look at that King vitamin vitamin
and what about like cocoa puffs you're
like okay like chocolate like that's
like some cool stuff Count Chocula cool
Barry loves blueberry Frankenberry yeah
you're like if it was cool yeah and you
would eat it too oh god ate the [ __ ] out
of that I ain't here saying that
breakfast breakfast lunch and dinner
like my momma come home with food and
I'd be like can we just have cereal and
I would eat cereal that's so wrong right
God you ever tried quitting sugar um no
I've tried to cut back on it here's what
I notice yeah um I had this experience
the other day in here I I judge my life
on my pee so I win the bathroom I pee
and it's bright yellow and I'm like I
took my vitamins I am I'm on the right
track
finally at 58 I'm on the right track I'm
taking vitamins now but also my yellow
peed bubbled up you know why cuz late
the night before I had a visit to the
freezer and that's some Ben and Jerry's
oh my gosh sugar makes my pee bubble
yeah and that tells me so good for me
God you know I hello bubbling pee I say
in life I God or whoever you believe in
I think they let you [ __ ] around your
body with two items and and you can live
forever like you know like my grandma
smoked and drank our life lived to be 99
but you know she never [ __ ] with candy
you know like Jerry Garcia did heroin
and cocaine forever and then Ben and
Jerry's comes out that ice cream named
after him assume he's dead in a couple
years
yeah
greed yeah greenie a dash of sugar is
Satan I know what's it like to kick it
well you kick dope a few times and you
know what that's like it's the same
thing man
mad body aches yeah severe body sweats
and night sweats okay
wake up in the middle of night like wha
yeah who rushes yeah like and a complete
depression like a massive crash of like
off how long's it like did you wean off
you just jumped off first you would
yeah right so then then then like how
long's that last what's day one like
yeah I got it Halon you don't even know
I don't care about the sugar so if I'm
going to kick its ass yeah me too day
two you start kind of like you're at the
store and you look down you see candy
and it starts drawing in you're like
[ __ ] I need some candy I could do this
I'm stronger than you Esther
Butterfinger yeah I'm a three-day three
is when a client starts kicking in that
sweat same same with like Samuel you're
like I can do a couple days I'm hurting
the day three it's like yeah maybe I'll
just do a little bit yeah I'm going to
just little chip a hip yeah yeah I'll be
okay I'll just chip and then day four I
will do it again yeah yeah and then
you're all starting to back over you
know so what's day five and six like
that you know they were all horrible for
about three weeks three weeks it wasn't
like home it wasn't like it just went
away you know what I mean like
cigarettes or dope it's out of your body
and a few days yeah this is way more
planet deep it's a psychological did you
watch your body change quick a man in a
matter of about a month my face changed
shape and I didn't really notice it
until a guy took a picture of me at the
podcast studio and I posted it up and
they went holy [ __ ] you look way
different yeah and I looked and thought
oh wow my face head shape you know it
was I saw something you posted on
Instagram today and you hashtag that
Dean yeah cuz I could just owning it
yeah yeah and I was I was like I never
thought of you as heavier
yeah you know it's weird when we're on
stage you know and you and you look at
band guys and you go are they're all fat
now and stuff yeah and you are and you
often wonder you go like well they're
rich is [ __ ] why don't they just have
like their own chefs and everything but
there's so many demons in your mind you
know what I mean like as you quit one
thing you start another I've got
addiction in my body so when I quit you
know sugar then it's shopping you know
anything like okay now I got to fill
this hole and it's some kind of dark
demon I know it you know and I just sit
back on it when I got really clean in
the late 80s around dr. feelgood time I
had that same experience right just like
I got addicted to working out and I
loved it and I would see people and they
say whoa dude and I'd be like what
they're like you literally don't even
look like the same guy so you go from
being young you can drink and do
everything and then all of a sudden you
know I got my manager said I had bison
head my head even got big yeah see
people's like their heads get big yeah I
know what it's like inflammation guys
yeah it's all sugar some booze you know
so there you look at blues man I had the
worst hangovers y'all oh me too me too I
drank the [ __ ] out of booze you know and
so your if you drink booze the whole
time then you're eating like [ __ ] you
know I'm 51 and I'm in better shape than
I've ever been in yeah I'm saying what
about like after you like hammered you
had that hangover you're like I'm
canceling everything today I'm on the
couch yeah I'm just which was your go-to
food because I have a shameful go-to
food mine would be pizza every time I'm
not happy with that I need a better
answer no I mean I would never just eat
pizza like to try it like soak up all
that yeah and I need to soaking up -
like it's like really bad orida tater
tots oh my god that's a specific thing I
know so I mean I was like really a bad
alcoholic and I would take them I mean
you know I I mean no I knew how to bake
yeah my demon said bake these things
they will absorb and then I would take
mayonnaise and tobacco sauce would mix
it up for a sauce and I was at Lowry
season salt
why do I even know about this Satan is a
powerful thing it really is and I would
soak all that up and buy it by 8 o'clock
at night so I'm going to call me hey
dude what I like you wanna you know go
out tonight you know chase some girls
and stuff I'm pretty hungover by 8:30
I'd be go hey let's meet up don't elect
shots yeah or Ida tater tots save me I
used to do an ad for alright a-alright
of Tater Tot yeah the best hangover food
on earth it's crazy to think about like
like your band is definitely geared
around party you know like know being
dangerous and outlaws and and that was
how life was supposed to be is rock and
roll
you know I mean you're supposed to live
fast die young as the corny thing goes
but you know after that Vince thing with
razzle it's pretty interesting to think
like I mean that is like whoa game over
right yeah I mean isn't it where do you
think it's weird that he would keep
partying later on I mean god that's like
a wild [ __ ] demon there I mean I had
overdoses so I kept doing drugs right
Tommy flipped cars and kept doing his
stuff you know the only smart guy and
motley crew is Mick Mars Wow you know
and to say this a smart guy and Motley
Crue's funny that's why when someone
goes Nicky man you're the brains behind
moniker ego is that an insult
ha ha ha but you know that that thing
whether it's sugar alcohol drugs [ __ ]
or shopping or obsession over anything
it's it's a hard thing to to get your
arms around and wrestle it to the ground
yeah it really is and I'm not judgmental
like when razzle died I remember
thinking to myself that like it wasn't
funny anymore right
and it blew my mind like I never thought
one of us or one of our friends could
die I mean we talked about it you know
man I'm gonna like die young yeah I'm
gonna be in the 27 club you know all
these stupid things you say in
interviews but then when somebody really
dies you're like damn dude
like I'm used to death now I'm 58 years
old like a lot of my friends yeah have
died and a lot of my heroes are dying
and you get to the place where family
members died but we were young yeah I
was in Martinique a little island with
meals lows our yeah and Robin Crosby and
it was I think one of the first times I
ever went on a vacation we were down
there we were having so much fun we went
to a club Med oh yeah I never even heard
of a club Med so all you can drink all
you can eat and it was a French island
so all the girls
the Rene topless yeah and I've never
seen that unless it was the back of the
tour bus yeah yeah like this is heaven
I'm moving here I'm gonna I'm going to
invest in Club Med and quit Motley Crue
this is the best there was people come
up to us on the beach sell us weed we
were doing shots we were like taking the
sheets off the bed making pirate flags
we're playing guitars I remember I wrote
keep your eye on the money and louder in
Hell in Martinique Wow Rob across seas
like that sucks
ah so your band sucks because your band
sucks because we were buddies yeah and
we flew from Martinique into Miami and
there was Vince on the cover of a
magazine on a magazine by the newspaper
Wow
we never you know no cell phone no email
don't even why is nothing I how many
days after it only been like a day well
so I went from like paradise like that
one of the peaks of my life I'm with my
best friend it was one of my buddies
great
we for the first time don't have money
problems we got girls who got drugs we
got alcohol we got food we're in the Sun
it's like life is great well let's get
back to reality I wrote a couple songs
yeah for an album you know theatre of
pain and I remember going to a payphone
and I I know to do I got a collect call
Wow
to the office and I called doc McGee and
I was like what happened they told me
and it's just like I remember that
flight from Miami back to Los Angeles
just going like I was in a trailer in
Idaho with the poster of Aerosmith on
the wall and now it's over and and and
and someone's dead like Invents like
what's Vince convinced evincing I go to
jail for his life with this what's this
this family of this this this guy that I
might have only met razzle once I um it
was mind-blowing that's just I remember
that because it's just kind of like oh
well they're done right when it was just
[ __ ] it likes the yes we were just we
made it in the playoffs yep we made it
into the playoffs everyone's like this
band is going to go they're going to go
to the Super Bowl yeah and and there was
so many mixed emotions because as a as a
dreamer you're like my dream is over and
as a human like you're struggling with
that so it's like are we mad at Vince
yeah are we sad for Vince are we what
are we and we're just as bad we're
drinking and driving ourselves and so is
everybody else
everyone planet Earth yeah I mean I
remember being in a car with Blackie
Lawless and Tommy and I had gotten my
first money a publishing cheque and I
took all of it
he has $6,000 yeah and I found a 914
Porsche badass it was exactly the
publishing money Wow so to pay for it I
had to call my grandparents who are dirt
poor so I need money to cover the
the registration thought that car had
nothing I had nothing but I had that car
man I was like in a band with a Porsche
and my buds were all in bands and the
chicks were crazy back then we were
driving down Sunset Boulevard I was
driving doing over 100 miles an hour
Yeah right three o'clock in the morning
I had a bottle of Jack Black II had a
bottle of vodka and Tommy I think had a
bottle of gin we got pulled over cops
pulled us over we got out we're all
black leather yeah he tops off that
thing that cops just said no what are
you guys doing because you guys are like
going way over the speed limits like
sorry dude we'll go to a party man oh
[ __ ] our brain yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's Hollywood zero and what is that
stuff we're like well you know it's just
some drinks so if you can't drink and
drive pouring out it poured out made us
walk yeah
to the garbage and throw the bottles
away and they said guys you need to go
home and then they gave us the keys and
we went home I remember the same thing
dude were you talking about now I'm in
also just right after that Vince you
know against in this horrible accident
and you know not only to razzle dye but
two other people were injured you got a
car hit yeah bad yeah so it was a big
goes a big eye-opener in a lot of ways
but not enough to stop everything didn't
it's trying yeah that makes me feel a
little sad yeah hey well you know it's a
it's an addiction you know I mean it's
like how are you been clean now 16 years
16 years no weed or anything you know
here is in 16 years no bunch of my
friends that are sober have you know
they're like I just need something and
they're like you know so they like start
vaping weed yeah like they don't really
want to become weed head something take
the edge off and I'm like I can't do
that
yeah I'll just be like be like just
going right back in the Sugar Land
getting that Count Chocula yeah things
you know I've got doing Captain Crunch
breakfast lunch and dinner yeah yeah
when 490 sing you know I weigh 493
hundred thousand dollar Ferrari I'm on
Sunset Boulevard trying to relive the
heyday and I'm drinking with a coke
strop my nose yeah and I you know crash
into Playboy Mansion building and I'm
dead
it's the hell way to go out you know
yeah that's where what you do a serpent
certain age you kind of want to live
right it's weird yeah like I want to see
where this goes
yeah like I say that all the time I'm
like man I go I can't wait to be like 80
I'm gonna have like a lot of gold teeth
I only got one so far yeah I got I got
space for two more [ __ ] covered in
tattoos yeah me [ __ ] eccentric
guitars cameras grandkids just crazy
artwork yeah just blowing through life
the way I want to blow through life
maybe I'll have a pink rolls-royce with
a skull and crossbone I'll wear
sunglasses at night eyes would be so bad
like I'd be super thick for reading coke
bottle Saigon
yeah coke bottle sunglasses man and I'll
just like I'll wear my guitar into the
clubs I'm going to go Club in it like 85
yes my sunglasses no shirt on with a
Hawaiian shirt and leather pants stink
eccentric [ __ ] you know I'm alive yeah
I'd do anything I want now absolutely
right now I'm on the line yeah
I'm not great 58 58 yeah it was
fantastic I'm pretty good let me ask you
something about that last night of the
crew tour it's almost two years now
right yeah it's a I guess it'd be a year
and a half right because there's New
Year's Eve yeah
and then I remember reading something
where you said you guys didn't even say
bye to each other that real oh yeah yeah
any communication with the guys now at
all I've I talked to Vince
me and Vince talk and text back and
forth he's a texture like me yeah and
I've reached out to Tommy and Mick
couple times I got any anything back you
know like when it ended man it didn't
end in a good way yeah we're all in
different ways but you know I guess like
the time went on I was like I'm just
going to reach out because like we were
like they're together in the beginning I
don't want to reach out put the band
back together right I was just like hey
man just like you know reaching out back
Nick I reached out to because it's crazy
I always wanted to have one of Mick's
guitars
yeah and like he is this white
Stratocaster that I just love I love
everything about it I'd say to him dude
like you know like you know can I buy it
and he'd be like no man I only have one
and then and then like you know as the
time went on I'd said see have another
one yeah and I go yeah I can't I buy
that one he goes all I only have two and
then he and I found out that he was
getting them custom made from fender
custom shop and I was like Greg can I
like get the number I'm gonna calm and
get one and he's like no man they do
they don't do that and just you know
time goes on after all these years
towards the end I remember the like
towards the end I said man I want it you
know get given to your guitars and I
gonna give you 25 grand for it like I'm
gonna buy my own guitars good talk I
don't care because he's McMorris I got a
tattoo of them yeah on my leg I mean I
carried him out of his house when he was
dying and I spoon-fed him a spoon fed
him to keep him alive took him to
doctors appointments every single day I
mean we didn't even know what was wrong
with him right and you know he's one of
my favorite our players in the whole
world and a lot of crazy people said a
lot of stuff to other band members and
there's a lot of weird lawyers involved
had to sue some people to make them step
back and I I never got that guitar and I
remember talking to a friend of mine and
I was like how so bummed because I
wanted to be like that that's not only
did I get it from Mick but it it would
be like I loved that guitar I love what
it sounds I love what he did to it he's
got the humbuckers in it yeah the way
it's relict that everything about it the
size of the headstock
so no this guy made me in McMorris
replica that's crazy you made it for me
I'm so happy with that guitar and took
some pictures I was like this is for MEC
Wow
you know then fans are stupid online
does some big Mars replicas you should
give it to mick mars i know i got it
because yeah I couldn't get the real one
yeah I'll give him the replica he'll
give me the real one yeah yeah that's
right but I but I love that guitar you
know what do you like to play in a band
with dudes that you don't really talk to
what is that like because that was a
long run and here's the thing you got to
realize that when these four guys got
together we we agreed on a common idea
right and everybody put their skin in
the game I don't think Mick Mars was a
punk rock fan right I'm a punk rocker at
heart always have been my attitude is I
love heavy metal but I was never a super
musician Muzo fan right I'd be like I
love what Eddie Van Halen's doing right
there but I didn't think about it
technically there's other guys in the
band that are technical so they put
their skin in the game I put my anarchy
in the game I'm a huge lyricist fan
that's like my driver for everything and
nobody in the band wrote lyrics I wrote
all the lyrics for the band that was all
the messaging and Vince had this voice
no one else sounded like that he had a
Spitfire Gatling gun like lead vocal
style he put his skin in the game no one
played like Tommy Tommy is 17 18 years
old when I met him I was a monster he
was hyper he's a hyper human being he
played hyper and I played simple and
that worked if I played super busy and
he played super busy yeah wouldn't it
sounded right so he had that I feel like
Tommy's energy was a big driver of the
band so you have all these guys and all
we do is we do what bands do you know
write songs and we play gigs and it's
like we're high-fiving each other when
that hot super hot chick wants to do two
guys at the same time the I am you know
it's like it was something that
we'll never experience with other human
beings and I don't know if anybody will
ever experience that because it's 2017
not 1981 and as these years ago each guy
meets a girl
they say that's that's I like that girl
come and keep her around that that girl
that I'm with can't sleep with the other
guys in the band that's how I am NOT
gonna tell anybody what her vagina looks
like that's when you like a girl oh man
what's it like down there oh man you
know I don't know man see that's what
lady baby you want to get a hamburger no
what about that chick the other night no
no no you're like oh you must like her
yeah yeah like you know like it's all
sudden you got four guys that like girls
and then they like limp with them all
said we're not like like dogpiling each
other at 8 o'clock in the morning when
everybody's hungover and like eating
McDonald's for breakfast because we
stole money up girl's purse yeah and
she's still passed out in the bathroom
he we become like you own a home and
like guys move different places yeah one
guy lives over here one guy lives over
here all of a sudden like you you do
things like make dinner we're before you
used to eat dinner at a restaurant and
dine and dash yeah together and then if
the waiter caught you you beat him up
like good luck yeah good luck you caught
us now now no [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah you
shouldn't have ever chased us yeah next
time we go in your restaurant we eat
you're not even to chase us because you
know we're going to kick your ass and
that mentality changes because you grow
up and that's a natural thing to grow up
and and and musically mature the next
thing you know it's like Nicky what do
you got down at go dad it's gonna go
like this don't shout don't shout long
tall he's like wah wah bah bah bah and I
Vince is like why is there so many
lyrics in here I got something to say
yeah we're gonna shout at the devil
music okay man he spit fire in that
stuff next thing you don't were at the
grocery store it's like
dear would you like zucchini or squash
tonight your filet mignon The Outlaw
goes away well I mean the Outlawz in
your heart
yeah but the men start to be come like
family-oriented it's not a gang anymore
yeah and it's so it's a gang and
rehearsal - gang in the studio it's a
gang on stage and ma'am you put Motley
Crue on stage we hate each other yeah if
you stood in the front row and you flip
Vince off I would jump in so I would
beat your ass Wow and Tommy you'd be
right on top of me like at you - that's
how we and people go these guys won't
talk to each other but if you [ __ ] with
one of them if somebody kicked in
Tommy's dressing room I'd be the first
guy than shank him yeah yeah and and
they're like these guys are [ __ ]
sickos they don't even talk but they
will beat your ass up if you even say
something bad about the band and as the
years went Tommy wanted to be a
different guy Yeah right you know I saw
the different faces with him I remember
I remember when he first got out of jail
you guys played the war field and he was
full-on hip-hop yeah yeah I was fell in
love with hip-hop yeah which I get you
know but I have no problem with this
right but it was weird for us we were
like whoa where's Tommy yeah and and
then he went through kind of a I don't
know what that exactly all kind of a.m.
guy a DM guy and in anyway so you know
he's young he's exploring yeah but
Tommy's thing was like well would it be
great if Motley Crue did this and then
my thing was like I want Motley Crue to
be Motley Crue so like if if I'm Angus
Young and I'm like here's a song called
highway to hell and then Tommy's Malcolm
young and comes in and goes hey man
would it be cool if we sound like these
other bands angus is going to say no
what are you crazy yeah and then there
became resentment and it felt like all
Nikki's holding the band back I want the
band to be Motley Crue and Tom and Mick
his passive you know we did some albums
with this producer named Scott Humphrey
made Mick feel horrible by his guitar
playing and it was think about you know
all sampling and all this and all that
so you know Mick started to kind of pull
out Vince's in and out of the band
at times it would be really wonderful
with
but here's the bottom line I have
nothing bad to say about him a the man
it was like we all wanted something in
the beginning right and later we all
wanted some different and and just
because I wanted it to be the same thing
and somebody else might have wanted it
to be a different version of that
doesn't make them a bad person right it
just means it was time for us not to be
a band anymore
yeah I get it cuz Kay's change like if
you look at you know like I always tell
people you know yeah motley crue one of
my favorites of all time but does that
mean I love the whole genre no no no
what I mean and and and I did when I was
young but as you get older you go all of
these other bands were just you know
well you know it's look at you get a
really nice meal and you get like you
know that that's stuff on the side and
you you take it off and put it on the
table you know it's like a garnish yeah
I think some of these bands that were
coming out in every era you're like oh
man look at this it's amazing you you've
got you know Motley Crue and you've got
guns roses and and what's that that's
its goods trickster found it found the
table yes yes I'm gonna eat that yeah
that tastes bad why'd you put that on
that way you put that on my plate you
say to the waiter in the chef and they
go because it makes it look pretty
yeah I don't care about pretty I'm
hungry yeah so you know music changes
people change it's okay to change it's
okay to be dysfunctional it's okay to
it's it's okay to let it go and you know
I haven't gone in the press or anywhere
and talked about about anybody in the
band and I don't think that I need to do
that I think that my frustrations and
motley crue probably equal other guys
frustrations and motley crue but when
you boil it all down you asked me if I
talked to anybody in the band I reached
out because it's like hey man like you
know how you guys doing and it back to
that first day in rehearsal like you
know I don't really care if you know
Mick Mars wants to fly from the [ __ ]
Eiffel Tower with a [ __ ] flame torch
playing [ __ ] Stevie Ray Vaughan
Lix and and you know i mean in a [ __ ]
push-up bra yeah it's like great that's
not why I'm calling
yeah yeah I don't need anything I'm not
calling you because I I'm going to try
to incentivize you to do something just
was just like reaching out you know but
in at first ended I wasn't reaching out
yeah man that's I'm just softening a
little bit my a sponsor told me one said
you know when you really got the program
it's when you learn to let things that
are hard soften you yeah I was like wow
man it's like as I going through a
divorce and I was like I am man
breaklines
over a cliff I'd be so happy be done
with this divorce she'd be dead yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah you just got to let like
what went wrong actually be a life
lesson and soften you a little bit so
for your next relationship for your next
bands for yeah shows that you do for
your next whatever was there ever going
to be a whiskey show at the UH never
it's just circulate immerse I think
Vince said something good to be fun and
Vince did mentioned to me and I was like
I go and and and I did I knew what he
was saying in his heart he is saying
that be great like we'll go play the
whiskey but yeah I saw and I told him
this we're gonna get offstage at one
o'clock in the morning right worth
Staples Center yep so we're going to
pack up all of our wet clothes and we're
gonna somehow get everything up to the
whiskey now I'm sure we'd have a second
set I just an SAR [ __ ] said yeah and
then we're going to blow in about three
o'clock in the morning and we're going
to be dog-ass tired cuz that was a long
day the last show I mean we it's more
filming and interviews and stress and
last night all that family hundreds of
people on the guest list wanting to say
hi and goodbye and I said I don't know
if I want to end it like being like I
can't wait to go to sleep
yeah and I'm playing livewire he's like
yeah I know it just would have been cool
to go back and
I understand like you know I remember I
had this one idea before the tour I
wonder and actually make a t-shirt I
just wanted to do motley crue a
Hollywood tour and I wanted to play a
Monday at the Troubadour a Wednesday at
The Whisky Friday at like the Roxy
Wow just I can do all the in Hollywood
maybe do a night to viper room that
would have been amazing and just go and
and just like play a bunch of different
songs yeah you know and stuff like that
was my idea and the band was like yeah
you know Vince had ideas Tommy had ideas
you know and it became four men with
different ideas right so sometimes you
have a band and you go there's four guys
with the same idea Metallica yep they
were like this is what we are we are
metal they did our name yeah it figured
it out even though they had some crazy
albums here on there yep turns out and
towards the end I think our version
figuring out was let's just let's like
leave our legacy for what it was you
know yeah I wanted to record our first
song we ever recorded together stick to
your gun yet as the last song
re-recorded make the last song we ever
did
I mean 3.5 second full circle well
circle but you got four guys and one
idea yeah so it's okay see a lot of guys
would sit here and go those guys man I
want to do this those guys are stupid
that guy was ugly that guy that guy was
drunk and that guy was fat and that guy
dumb he wanted to be one that guy wanted
to be electron Nikki's a
stick-in-the-mud man he didn't want to
change yeah you know what watch this let
it be cool like it was what it was and
you know what's cool about Motley Crue
dysfunction yeah you have the danger of
it got what anytime it's going to
explode you I never knew
yeah we sometimes only made three songs
yeah it did many times
BAM blow up on stage I'm watching the
show called animal kingdom yeah that's
Motley Crue crew they're our family but
they're dysfunctional yeah well you had
a singer and I described this about
Sebastian
Bock you pray for a complete lunatic
outlaw and then when you get them you
try to tame them you know I talked to
the skid-row guys before and it really
comes down to again the fact that you
are not 21 years old and you have a home
and you have a wife and everyone in the
band if they've got they've got what
they want but they also want a little
bit of peace I don't want to wake up
every day the [ __ ] drama yeah I don't
want drama every [ __ ] day of my life
I'm so happy that motley crew made a
decision to move on because there's no
more emails about things that you're
like we can't even agree on the goddamn
artwork
I'm buleria like [ __ ] dude it's artwork
yeah like you guys win it's 2% smaller I
mean you know I mean yeah that it
becomes about other stuff but like with
with Skid Row I don't think they want
this like dude if you could just sing
yep but you can't dad when it comes down
to that because if you got a guy who
wrote all the songs but he get to get
zero glory for it like you wrote all the
songs in motley but you got all the
glory but if you didn't it would kind of
ride you a little bit right like the
Vince was the focal point of a van but
it never was in your band
all the guys were the focal point song
Ryan C I didn't know that yeah and
that's the thing I don't know who wrote
the songs of Skid Row yeah I just like
the band a lot of people don't know who
wrote songs and Motley Crue well the
crew is a is a band that will be on the
radio and streamed and beat herdin
movies and and talked about yeah
remember that band drummer flew
upside-down the bass player was shooting
fire at him and he died no did that
happen let's go to Google yeah Tommy Lee
died Nikki Sixx killed Tommy Lee that
never happened idiot pass the ketchup
yeah I'll try to say that combo klore
yeah it grows and it grows and it grows
you know
and and I think in in general people get
so hung up and I don't care who writes
song right look if it's a good song I'm
going to play bass on it at what point
do the guys in the band start saying hey
I want to write songs because you're
writing the first year at records are
complete masterpieces you know what I
mean and then you got to get that fact
becomes a friction because of publishing
and identity right like hey I don't
think it was ever about publishing her
identity wasn't about just artistic no I
just think that people like learn to
write songs when I when we started the
band I was a songwriter I wrote songs
for other bands before I was in a band
actually there was a band in Burbank and
I used to work at this factory a steel
factory and one of the guys worked there
and he had a band they played in a
garage so I hung out with them I had a I
had a bass but I wasn't in a band and I
wrote all the lyrics for that band Wow I
was like Bernie Taupin just Ghost Rider
Ghost I just wrote them and gave them to
him they're like in the garage spitting
out my words I'd hang out I never even I
don't even know what ever happened to
any of it they probably don't even know
that yeah that you're famous like they
never know it was the same dude yeah
that's amazing right they got like some
Nikki Sixx originals yeah I think it is
recording right now that you gave me
yeah like make a little bit of money mid
seventies Wow my god knows my wife's
cell everything that's you know mine is
like if I [ __ ] if I if I if I was a
girl and I was on my period they'd be
selling my old tampons I like on eBay
it's like Nikki Sixx nose hairs for sale
haha that's nice it's really [ __ ]
nice but you know I I think that it
became about people you know in a band
when I go here's this idea called looks
like ill yeah everybody puts their skin
in the game it does what they do Tommy
does what he does make those videos I do
it I do Vince you're like that's cool we
go play it people go that's cool we
record it and then one day somebody said
circles you
No I got this idea and I'm going to
bring it to the band I'm going to bring
it to the band I got this song idea it's
great like if there's four guys and two
guys have ideas yeah that's less work
for me and better shot that we're going
to have more songs and some diversity
that one writer might write in one style
and the guys in Vince never but Tommy
and Mick and mostly Tommy because
Tommy's into recording right so Tommy
like Bill win program stuff and building
something you see where that ended with
him he's like really into being the
studio and loops and you know electronic
music and so but you know he was coming
up with lots of ideas he wrote home Sue
Ellen write that way home sweet home
came together I wrote the part that's on
piano I wrote that on guitar when I was
17 years old well I mean play in that
and play in that I know what it was and
we were leaving a rehearsal one day and
there was a piano and Tommy had always
sit down piano we're leaving we're at si
our and I said dude can you play this on
piano ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
I think I just sang all there dudes for
whatever it's you get the point
yeah yeah and Tommy goes ding ding ding
ding did it and it did and I go that's
cool you know I'm a dreamer and I my
heart's a gold that's come here there's
something something told all bald gold I
don't know give me a piece of paper
quick yeah
damnit wanna dude come back that fast
sorry doing I'm on my way oh what's that
thing in that Aerosmith song I like lame
sweet oh and and it was that and Tommy
like wrote the piano part and then I
can't remember who our other parts I
wrote the way that song came together
really fast we were like we're leaving
si our think we're going out to do
something and we're like man that could
be like our dream on yeah and it was and
it was fun I never always customer would
play it Tommy would run
rehearsal back to the drums yeah so the
piano would be on one side like down on
the floor yeah then the stage would be
there and the band would be up on the
stage he'd run up jump on his drums but
bump bump bump yeah that's a that's a
Smasher man I already yesterday and it's
funny like that songs played a million
times in the radio yeah and I wish we'd
recorded it better like you know we
actually had a producer that said we're
going to record this sonically better
right but I don't think we kind of like
a November rain yeah a pretty big
youngji should be a little bigger so but
like a great example of Tommy as Tommy
was like programming all this stuff and
he had this thing shout shout shout any
any come to my house he played it and I
go it's a little close to the other song
I know I just like the idea and I go I
was just reading this book primal scream
scream shout shout I go let me just roll
the bass in here and he's like yeah dude
and then we were like working on it and
I was like bad eh eh
and I'm like something some like Jill
Perry would do it mix like started
playing that thing I go remember when I
saw you in a bar BAM and you're playing
slide can you do Wow Wow
like on the slide yeah and then a lot of
the lyrics I was just reading that book
by Arthur jenoff and I was like oh
here's the lyric here's the lyric flat
and then I was like kind of going
through this thing with therapy where
that's why I was reading the book about
my mom and dad so the song ended up
being about my mom and dad Wow yeah that
lyrics easy for you yeah well that was
the only hard part for me you know to me
like I could write the [ __ ] out of tunes
you're a comedian yeah and you're fast
you could write lyrics really fast if
you did this one simple thing shut the
[ __ ] critic off yeah you're right
you're right you don't do it on stage do
you now when you're on stage do you go
wonder with that guy over there thinks
yeah you don't give a [ __ ] you just go
and and and sometimes I bet you stumble
your tongue gets tied you forget what
you're going to say
do you stop no [ __ ] way you just keep
going to going on and my theory is
big-ass piece of paper and I just write
non-stop non-stop I keep writing if
someone starts talking I'm like shut up
I don't what are you writing I don't
know right I don't know you know and
this channel 3 if you're just going you
just start writing soon as you look down
you go
I'm the dumbest guy on earth dumbest
kinder but sometimes you go oh that one
thing that's great we do it again I'm
going to start with the one thing yep
and then sometimes if it's like a line
and I like it I'll put it in the middle
of the piece of paper and then I'll
start again with stream-of-consciousness
yeah when I hit that line I'm like what
are you doing you're in my way I got wom
and jump off you then and you have to
trick yourself yeah you have to trick
yourself another great trick is to
surround yourself by inspirational
things minor antique books so if I have
both books around me I will be going
going going and I'm like I'm my brains
going no man they're not going to like
this all and there's a radio so I can
play this all man my wife hates me oh
[ __ ] my dogs took a [ __ ] on my new shoes
on it's like [ __ ] give me a book I
open it up and I point to a piece of
paper and if it says spaghetti
yeah I'm [ __ ] I have to use spaghetti
as the next word if it says forever or
if it says in the darkest pit of your
soul I'm like in the darkest pit of your
soul darkness pit of your soul spaghetti
no darkest pit of your soul and you
start going from there and the idea is
to never allow yourself to actually
breathe now have to just go and not
think and think man that's the worst
thing you ever do to yourself is think
you think about when you're playing you
make a mistake you're making love you
think about it oh I should do this oh I
should do that just stick your dick in
it and go and when you're writing lyrics
stick your dick in ago and say we're
songwriting I'm not a great musician but
I will not stop you wrote the [ __ ] out
of some great songs man I mean
classics I we talked about the s
Festival when I was on your shelf and
I've come to conclusions and I want to
try to do a documentary on it you know
it's like my my goal now but my other
dream documentary is Oakland Coliseum
Dan the greens and I remember I heard
her remember that 87 man it was one of
the greatest day and it was you guys and
the girls girls girls to a Whitesnake on
the huge record poison Jed boy and
there's somebody else on that but that
was like to me that was kind of like of
course you had the big record you know
dr. feelgood but he that was felt like
this is the peak of the scene right and
the sound and everything we're in own
Coliseum 60 70 thousand people girls
girls girls tour and Whitesnake speaking
you know poisons got a huge family
headline you had not we did yeah well
you're gonna love this yeah I love that
you don't melt like Jimmy it was me to
say oh I talking about still to this day
like yeah did you know I played 60,000
day on the green I mean you play a huge
crowd spring but that was such a crown
jewel that I've had like a shell in
America I've been freebasing for three
days yeah free basin and I didn't didn't
show up you didn't show up and show up
no one could find me oh that's right you
guys didn't go on for like you went on
super late yeah like we're waiting
around so they had to find me yeah where
were you I was burrowed in to the heroin
house freebasing and they had to
basically kick my door in yeah they put
me in a limo right they took me to Van
Nuys Airport and put me in a private jet
Wow
by myself whoa flew me there to a very
pissed off band whoa what the [ __ ] is
going on you're shooting up again I go I
wasn't shooting up as freebasing yeah
different they're different now and not
doing
[ __ ] anymore freebase and I remember
like just being so [ __ ] out of it on
state Wow
and I flew back in that jet because you
got to pay for a round-trip yeah alone
and I just remember being alone flying
through the night after playing that
crowd going my band hates me I'm this is
a bottom for me man
it's like why would I do that to my fans
why take something to be proud about and
I just like remember just flying on the
jet I went home same night
it was like I walked in [ __ ] doors
[ __ ] up how can I was just like hey
that that was like getting towards the
end man I was like this is stupid
yeah yeah yeah so like a lot of people
mentioned a on the green and I'll be
like I didn't really remember much about
it
wow what a bummer man yeah you know I
I'm not saying wait I took mushrooms at
that show well we're in the same place
yeah
Harry Mary's just you should come by my
house first I did some freebase and you
know and I never never grabbed me like
the first couple of hits were great but
the next day I was never like I got to
do that again no me neither
yeah there I had a girlfriend that liked
the freebase so she'd be like you know
she'd be like cooking up some bass and I
just be like oh yeah I give me a hit of
that and then I'd be like up for two
days yeah but it was never like I'd
never like think to myself hey guys want
to get together bass yeah yeah the weird
thing it takes a lot of work to so much
work I mean and just cooking that stuff
up and you know I'm not a good cook
anyway yeah the baking soda combo and
you [ __ ] it up and you'd lose blow I'm
just like two grand I'm just lost below
and I beat I called the dealer I go I
need I need more below my dealer yeah
like was the best dealer on earth it was
a Hollywood dealer he's a Hollywood deal
not the best the luckiest really yeah
cuz I just be like hey man you got ten
grand worth of heroin on my way Wow and
like you know and I would do stuff like
I would take ten thousand dollars to the
heroin and I would like put them in
bindles like
like methodically like from this amount
and I'm on now all the way down to day
39 I'd be like hey on day 30 I'm going
to be able to get off this heroin Wow
and he go came in and the day for I'd
call him you got into $10,000 in heroin
oh [ __ ]
$10,000 guys came over a bunch of my
buds came over and a bunch of chicks and
we just did all the junk I'm imma start
over wow man I started over a lot what
what got you into shooting up like I
never got into it because it was always
like that so that's the like lat you
know what I mean like I did all the
drugs but to shoot it up is just kind of
like I don't know it was just like this
is business it felt wrong to me in a
weird world I why did it yeah the first
time I ever shot up was with Robyn Cosby
oh really yeah we lived in an apartment
on Coldwater Canyon and so did he I
lived on the second level and I was a
like a one room with a loft thing at the
top there was a sink up there and and
and I put a bed up there yeah and then
just this room downstairs and then Robyn
had just a room down below and we were
great buds were best friends nothing
together end and he knew this guy named
smog vomit smog vomit tested the
Horsehead why detection or is that
Australia John Key's yeah straight
junkies came over and their friends from
I believe San Diego and came over and um
we would smoke that [ __ ] now remember
guys like you want to try this and I
just looked at the needle I said [ __ ]
yeah and I did it and I I threw up on
myself and passed out on my floor and I
woke up and I was just like is she and I
felt like [ __ ] and I was like that's
awesome oh yeah man is like to me but
you know guys my band would be shooting
up and I was just like man that's just
like I would trip out on it yeah and I
thought it's a really interesting
interesting thing you know i associated
it with the same thing associated with
like Hells Angels Vagos guns
knives heavy metal punk rock it's all
the things I love yeah I wanted I want I
want a car goes to fat just wanted
everything I never had any real roots I
only got roots when I grew my own roots
yeah I became my own tree but I didn't
have a mom or a dad or really a family
my grandma and grandpa yeah but was
really I felt a little bit like a
tumbleweed my whole life yeah it was
like shooting up hell yeah
can I Drive and do it too yeah I mean
you know I was just a stupid [ __ ] I
remember this girl she was this band
called 45 Grave her name was Dinah
cancer Wow yeah she I can't definitely
and she had a coffin and I used to [ __ ]
her in the coffin Wow shoot up Wow crazy
[ __ ] why you're on dope I never did you
know I never saw you get your because
coke is this it's done you got your
moments yeah you got your mom you get
that coke ticket oh yeah you know now
they got like viagra so dudes can just
do coke and viagra together I never
gotta give this you know I remember when
ecstasy came out and I just remember I'm
so mad like why couldn't that come out
there's so many things that came out and
I like white why why did I only get like
coke and heroin so those are just those
are the ones who stuck around
they're the mainstays they're like steak
and you know vegetables and potatoes but
then they came out with all this other
special sauces and people would be like
you know anytime you make music that
only goes you know some [ __ ] yeah and
you have like a hundred thousand people
all going this is the greatest moment of
my life I go have you heard what Joe
Perry plays on rocks an album like are
you you want to go back to 2 to 2 can we
talk to Mick Jagger for a second that's
why that drug was invented yeah to fool
the masses and say that was great that's
good
god that's a good idea we're going to
create a festival around this and
350,000 people are going to stand there
and go do and you don't have to learn
any instrument to write any songs now
you can just like grab a couple things
move them around and if you put a mouse
head on you're like the kiss like DJs
yeah that guy's cool he's got a mouse
head yeah I know we found gold man now
it's funny man yeah now hey I asked you
about was I'm a huge car guy and you're
a huge car guy and also motorcycles that
you ride any mortal or no that's long
over I mean here the reason like one of
the reasons as like girls girls girls
video yeah I'm like that's the dream I'm
going to get a record deal I'm gonna
have a Harley and every night I'm just
going to ride to the rainbow that's all
I wanted yeah I did rainbow health your
dream and yeah and just [ __ ] do drugs
and be up and down the strip that was
the dream I almost died enough times on
a motorcycle I had a bike that was built
for me by the Hells Angels and the chain
locked up oh yeah
and I just remember it was before the
helmet laws and I it gave me that that
weird moment where I went oh I didn't
know that you were right there mister
pavement [ __ ] yeah and then a bunch of
guys like I knew you know Billy Idol got
hit yeah and this guy we used to ride
with me and Tommy used to ride with the
Angels this guy Stu Mountain Thousand
Oaks California had a motorcycle shop
and leave it to Tommy Lee and Nikki Sixx
in like this really nice area to find
the only motorcycle shop where the Hells
Angels hung out yeah so there's me and
Tommy yeah going back to our mansions
yeah with our pretty wives but in the
daytime we wrote our motorcycles and
hung out the Angels and we'd ride with
them all the time they'd protect us Wow
ride to circle around us there was a
ride that they asked me to go on and I
couldn't for whatever reason I mean
Tommy rode up to San Francisco with them
camp
out I really love motorcycles on
motorcycle culture and the music and
good people that could [ __ ] people
totally and that this ride was happening
and stood aside to go around there was a
truck going slow and they were out in
the middle of nowhere
and decided to go around and when he
went around a another truck came and hit
him head-on whoa
and like he evaporated Wow and I just
remember going like you know I think
it's time to start driving convertibles
right right I miss my motorcycle yeah I
mentioned my wife one of those three
will one oh yeah tell me I'm sorry I'm
not allowed to get that oh oh you're my
joke every time I'm at a gas station a
guy comes every guys ah
nice bike I would have one of those but
the wife won't let me you know it is I
go I don't that's my bike
yeah I can love when people like grown
men will just tell you how they're wild
my wife doesn't care if I ride recently
she doesn't want you to have the three
wishes what the three issues I'm gonna
ride you're going to get it you're gonna
get a chopper again um but no I thought
about the three-wheeler thing so I'm
like I could have like okay my my
O'Doul's
there are doing you drink I do sometimes
really bloated but sometimes you know I
just it make me feel like wow I'm on the
freeway I'm in the 101 I'm riding with a
beer and I'm playing like get your wings
by Arrowsmith yeah and I'm untouchable
and then my wife's no you because you're
in a three-wheeler if everyone's going
to go is that Nikki Sixx in a
three-wheeler I go I could get the
helmet with a spike and I could paint
that thing black with like skull flame
hilarious I'm not gonna have the loudest
exhaust I have a sounds how about
$100,000 sound system on this thing how
will crush sticky fingers BAM everyone
on the freeways like look at that badass
she goes no you're on a three wheeler
yeah is there a trike right I go look at
those badass guys and she goes all those
guys were really old yeah yeah she goes
just stick with you Jeep or get a real
bike you
out of jeep yeah when I saw you just
customized it out what are some of the
coolest cars yet you've had some
Lamborghinis I've never been a
Lamborghini out for eyes a lot of
Ferraris know Ferraris my worst Ferrari
story is I got a brand new what's my
best in my worst story so I go into the
Ferrari dealership on Ventura Boulevard
I have army boots on yeah super short
shorts with a mushroom patch tattooed
where my dick is yeah that's it a bunch
of changed in no shirt you're going in
with like the with the Lemmy short yeah
just a daisy dukes holding with a
mushroom of your dick yeah that was me
and I blew in there yeah and when I
walked in the ding the door goes ding
and they look up and it's like remember
was really hot outside I'm so nice and
sign as I cos it's nice and here yeah
guy from behind the desk excuse me can I
help you and I go I want to buy a
Testarossa if you have one oh yeah the
guy goes um excuse me hold on and he
goes in the back yeah and then another
guy comes out that's always bad yeah
yeah because I throw you out and I'm
gonna filter yeah and I go I goes yeah
I'm the manager here can I help you with
something I mean I thought I was
homeless or something and I said yeah I
want to buy Testarossa and he goes do
you know much they are and I said well I
go you guys are probably selling them
above sticker price I think they're 175
I think you could go on for about 236
right now I'll give you $225,000 cast
you have it I got the cash yeah cash and
the guy goes uh well there's one in the
back and I think he still thinks I'm
going to be taken away in a pen he was
in the back yeah red one with Tanika
that's exactly what I want I'll take it
Wow and he goes what do you mean that
good you can I take it now and he goes
well we we have to prep it I go cool I'm
going to go get a hamburger and I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna drive it home
yeah and I came back I had a brown paper
bag - a brown paper bag where did you go
to the bank to get that huh and they
would just give me the kid my [ __ ]
money I know but you know they are
uh yacht they we had together like four
banks to get that I took it I bought it
in cash and I drove it home
why did guy visitation his pants like
and I think when I drove off there to
all of them were standing on the curb
yeah like it was like a scene out of a
movie and they were like did that just
happen
I had no idea I heard that slash that
happened / - he went to the Porsche
dealer in Beverly Hills he goes in
crusty leathers / you know uh you know
illusionary / - garbage / yeah he goes
in there and the guy goes can I open it
yeah I want to get a twin-turbo 911 the
guys like yeah yeah just walks by and
ignores them next guy walks by goes hey
I want to get a twin-turbo 911 guys like
Josh excuse me sir no one's talking on
some guy that's the car washer guy that
tt details I hate your / because yeah
they I want to get I want to get a poor
said twin-turbo and he goes and tells
the guy the guy comes over and he goes
oh sorry about that he goes I want to
but only if this kid gets the Commission
I love I know right the kid got the
commission from what I hear you know
they could be a myth but I love it man
what cars were your favorite horse AG
I'm a 911 freak I've been looking at
Porsches again Oh God
like II got to get into the air-cooled
911 I I had a twin-turbo yep lowered
like there was only as much rubber Wow
an inch was stupidest thing every day
because I was always banging up the rims
yeah I've had a biggest whaletail on it
yeah and it was the first time I had a
Tiptronic oh yeah and I love that car
but what happened was I Drive a lot and
I got really tired of being beat up in
it
oh yeah cuz you're silver like a go-kart
yeah so when that car went I ended up
getting a Corvette oh yeah it was like
because I wanted a convertible
so I was like I'm going to get the
Corvette Convertible so I had that for
about a year and I loved it even though
it's still a Corvette it wasn't a
Porsche and I'd have a Ferrari
Testarossa as well obviously and then I
then I ended up with some like a 32 Ford
and then like a Chevelle 70 Chevelle
convertible and I was like I want to
just like get back into a sports car
convertible and I bought a California
for our California yes I love those love
that that's a great car I had that for a
couple years and I told the guy when I
went in I said hey um when I want to get
that car was a 458 Spyder
I go so I'm going to take this car and
then when the lease is halfway up
because I lease my cars I tell the
government I Drive them to work yeah
yeah and then I'm going to come back and
you're going to give me the same car for
this price because that's not gonna
happen okay I go in there with the car
yeah dirty I've washed it and go hey I'm
thinking of extending my lease I get
that car and you can have me for two
more years or I'm going to turn this car
in a me get a portion yeah so I got the
458 Wow I drove that for a while by the
gray car rate card Wow
and then I got the Jeep recently yeah
and I'm looking at Porsches so what do
you want to get like vintage well no
again I want to get brand new Tiptronic
convertible what I suggest I get Targa
something that I can I mean it's easy to
dry it up it's like comfortable I need
sound system I need to make my business
calls and either listen to music and I
don't want to feel like I've gone to the
races when I get you know to where I'm
going
tar gas forget the new target is
phenomenal they say it's my favorite car
because they've got the top targeting
like you're 914 adds the glass piece
goes up like this it goes down into the
trunk and it's all sealed and primo it's
now
like a shitty convertible wear them
can't see and it starts leave Kenya and
it's a beautiful body it's got that
metal piece between you know the roof
and the glass and they come in the
coolest colors man like that like old
70s blue I mean could I do that I mean
can I get away with that if I'm going in
right now and you're like I know Nikki
Sixx yeah then I'm I'm I'm gonna pick
his car for him yeah I'm like Dean I
think I want a black one you're like
look I need you to think outside the box
first absolutely 58 years old you've
done a lot of stuff you're wearing a
flowered shirt right now yeah you can
still rock the leathers yep what what's
my color I go to the [ __ ] Pink Panther
pink
I can't let me get beat up I'm not a
flashes how so beat me up no way man
here's the thing I just talked to Rogan
about this because man you like those
wild colors but those colors they made
like you know Miami blue yeah they got
one that's called mint green it's like
chocolate chip mint ice cream colors
that is [ __ ] those colors they're all
like those Art Deco colors you know
those things are way cooler than black -
maybe black is I got a white Jeep yeah I
just can't deal with the dirt Jerry I
can't go it either you know what's great
about the 911 it always looks the same
yeah except for the [ __ ] era the 993
where they did these ugly headlights
when spills off to the side nobody wants
that but all the other ones from six
wins that costs no than a new a new one
a new one like 130 seeing compared to a
Ferrari yeah cheap and state of the art
card I could gin my coaster sitting over
there I could get two and give you one
yeah what colors she get you should get
army green yeah
army green badass your enemy yeah
absolutely fine everybody them are you
rich no I'm poor
no cuz I I meant my manager yeah cuz you
you know you that tour was big money
right yeah it was what a year and a half
I don't I don't care about that kind of
money I understand that I understand but
what I'm saying is you know you sign
this thing and I can ever tour as the
crew
again or whatever we've heard that a
million times on every bed yeah I mean
and then I said oh you know the money's
gone but you know I watched recently the
minimalist documentary and I try to get
myself but I watch you and your exact to
me who you're up late and you Motley's
gone and you just start buying stuff
right and you're filling houses and
you're going Qatar number seven honey
you got a base you brought and you're
just like me you're the same [ __ ] way
you go this is the best base I've ever
owned yeah I need to get four more I'm
the same way I get a watch and I go I
love this I want to get this black face
one now yeah when I got a watch guy yeah
I don't even my watch my watch it says
it's uh it's 4:00 a.m. yeah everybody
said it not what I said it I have a
phone it's just all about the peace but
I was smart this car D a solid-gold yeah
Santos XXL yeah they don't even make
this yeah for what I paid for this you
much bling I could have I know I could
make rappers look poor yeah I mean how
stupid am i that I'm buy a watch yeah
because of the guts and because of all
that and - what why did I do that why do
I not just buy gold well watch is to
mayor a lot like vintage guitars they're
handmade you know they're [ __ ]
completely cool pieces of art and
they're they're going to last way beyond
us yeah and I mean and they and there's
something about a watch to me that I
don't give a [ __ ] about time but it's
what went into it it's like a 59 junior
like you got you know man it's what went
into it and and and you know there's not
a lot of things that are handmade
anymore yeah yeah I love handmade stuff
handmade shit's gone and made knives so
I know I love your knives photos so you
asked me about money yeah okay so the
best advice I ever got and I will hand
it out like candy yeah look at this
we're wrapping it up yeah
wrapping it up bring it back to the
candy
if you make $1 and in my case I'm the
50% tax bracket
yeah and I have a manager cost me 15
percent he's fifteen fifteen Wow
I've been with him for Doc McGhee no
Allen Kovac I've been with him for 23
years personal manager yeah all my
everything oh I got everything so doc
didn't manage motley crue he did in the
early days I got two guys so um I I'm
trying to think of a way to do this so I
take 20% of my net net net net net and
then never touch it so if my I have to
lose off the top 65 cents that's just
called 60 so I have 40 cents left on a
dull on every dollar you're on 40 cents
but it costs me 30 cents to live right
I'm only putting 10% away only putting
10 cents per dollar I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot I 20% everything I make so
what if my life has to adjust to that so
I can have Porsches and Ferraris I going
to have guitars I can have candy you
have anything I'll have a stripper pole
on my motorcycle my trike yeah I
complain but if if I'm only putting 19
percent away I'm an idiot I have to save
20 percent of everything I do and I've
been doing that for as long as I know
and that 20 percent gets impacted and
impacted and impacted and I invest in
California California municipal bonds
because you get 5% non tax return on
that so you make 5% if you have $1 in
there you make a nickel Wow and the next
year you make 5% on a dollar five right
you do that for 30 years and it grows
and it grows and grows and and this
times in my life were like I go man I'd
really like to do that but I'm not
touring and it's not going to work out
20% and you'll never have to worry again
because when the rainy day comes you're
like [ __ ] you know that there's
something that's growing over here yeah
it's the best best thing you can ever do
people don't do it you've been doing
that how long long as I can remember
Wow well why do you let you live in
Calabasas right I did and then I move
because the paparazzi where do you live
now I live out in Thousand Oaks why do
all the rockers move out there do you
ever feel like I I always felt like if
I'm ever because you've seen like the
hunting dog on the porch yeah we're
hunting dogs
yeah the porch our days are gone we're
lucky if an old hunting dog comes mine
we can hump er yeah maybe there's a bird
off in the distance and we're like let's
see the bird we like pretend to point
and our owners like oh good job Nikki
you haven't do you ever feel like if I
were violated in the Hollywood Hills
still I would be fully alive and or oh
we did born New York City no no I'm out
there yeah and this is how I look at it
okay so a big fish small pond uh-huh I
don't care I'm married yeah I'm
monogamous I'm loyal I love my wife
but when I walk around Westlake I still
they say that I'll bet a hunting dog
hahaha they're like this [ __ ] Nikki
Sixx underwear that hun dog he's a king
he's royalty yeah it's awesome I go into
Hollywood I got to compete with these
young guys I got to kill them tell me
I'm good overdose and die so I can feel
better by myself so the only way to
survive yeah is to fake myself into
believing I'm still you know happening
that's from being us that's from being
off stage now that I mean because you
still need back a Nikki Sixx right you
know today right not me but now I I like
I I'm kind of like I'm a guy that like
goes into his closet and like is like a
scientist and comes up with stuff and
then I come out yeah it's like damn I
didn't see that coming or like recharge
have energy feel good and I can't do
that when people are pecking at me all
the time so I have to put myself in a
quiet area yep so then I can be creative
and then and then then I go into the
world and I go do my stuff you know I
want to write some songs over there you
don't want to write a song with me yeah
yeah yeah oh I'll make you create you'll
be like dude I
since the song's called dog you're like
the dog yeah
like okay go back go back you can't stop
at the dog you have to say I need 500
pages about the dog hahahaha what if we
ever write together you didn't have to
do what you do on stage I'm there I go
for it let it flow oh you know I write
now in no rhyming dictionary I know I
say run the track I put the headphones
on and I just start throwing it out
that's how I do it oh and you're great
time yeah it comes from somewhere else
yeah it goes comes all my records have
been like I've been [ __ ] and
distrubing and I go there's a man on the
highway and I'm like ah what does that
mean but it's stuck and then I just
where is he's on the highway you got a
favorite comedian you Wow you got to
come out again yeah I know me next time
will be well thank you I can't thank you
enough for doing the show it's a total
dream guest I could talk to you for
hours
thanks them and everybody's like oh [ __ ]
is great I think I do stand-up comedy
what do you think she do it just one
time two times I'll get eaten for lunch
I'd go up I'd say [ __ ] you guys what are
you [ __ ] looking at yeah and you're
like yet there is he's back he's he's
not Thousand Oaks anymore you can do you
could do storyteller it's like Rollins
Oh got great [ __ ] stories and you
know how to tell us there's me now I saw
him in Germany or so he was like sitting
at a table eating by himself
again old and he's just like oh my god I
wanted to go over and say you know hi
Henry owners at mr. Rollins
right and he made eye contact with me
and I felt ashamed he's intense well you
know I think he's what he's what we wish
we could be he's at peace
he doesn't need items and stuff other
than vinyl he'd just travel around I
felt like a just a you know like a
soldier out there man well I love him I
want guns
and knives and yeah put a new Porsche
I'm going to buy tonight yeah yeah I
want to go any when you get it we're
going to go buy it let's do it all right
thanks
Thank You Man there you guys go tune in
tune in next week again - let there be
talk and don't forget to leave a review
and subscribe thank you guys
you